salut la team menthe à l'eau c'était une
entrée tout en retournement pour fêter
cela dit aujourd'hui pas de blog je vous
parlais des placements produits a
également des titres pita clic il a
écrit ultime dans son titre
ça doit être un but à cliquer est ce que
le fait que j'écris plus ta clique dans
mon titre ça fait un titre plus ta
clique du titre la mise en abyme du
titre put à clips sur youtube depuis
quand même peu de temps depuis quelques
mois à peine et j'ai donc découvert
cette effervescence pour le titre put un
clic c'est-à-dire que un titre plus
tacler de base c'est une promesse que
beaucoup trop fort par rapport au
contenu est ce que ça veut dire qu'on
doit pas utiliser de l'ironie dans les
titres ou est-ce qu'on peut pas parler
du thème de la vidéo dans le titre la
première fois qu'on m'a dit ah ça c'est
un titre plus ta clique c'est quand
j'avais fait une vidéo sur gilles verdez
et joey starr lors de la fameuse baffe
j'avais trouvé ça assez intéressant pour
parler de la communication non-violente
la cnv récemment quand j'ai fait la
vidéo sur le fait que j'allais me poser
la question sur le fait de fermer la
chaîne ou pas est-ce que c'était un bon
projet que de continuer à faire ce
projet j'avais appelé la vidéo fermeture
définitive
et bien croyez le ou non avant que vous
me disiez que c'était un peu ta clique
je pensais naïvement que c'était une
bonne blague
belle ironie tout ça pour vous dire que
je vais pas me prendre la tête sur les
titres d'une manière générale en fait je
me de titres que j'ai envie de mettre je
cherche pas si commercialement il est
bon ou pas si c'est du pique nique ou
pas je veux juste que le titre
correspondent à la vidéo et si je trouve
un truc qui me fait marrer mais le truc
qui me fait marrer ça va pas plus loin
que ça mais parlons également des
placements de produits beaucoup de
youtube en font parce que c'est un vrai
moyen pour gagner sa vie pour financer
ses projets youtube
à ce jour je n'ai jamais fait sur la
chaîne j'ai des propositions que j'ai
refusé parce que je ne voyais pas
l'intérêt ni artistique ni du produit
par rapport à vous ou alors parce que la
personne n'avait pas assez discuté avec
moi je le vois comme ça je reçois une
proposition de placement de produit
c'est pas c'est pas sale c'est pas le
mal incarné ça peut être hyper
intéressant pour financer un projet pour
la chaîne ou tout simplement pour
rentabiliser un petit peu toutes ces
vidéos
mais dans ces cas là j'estime que la
personne en face doivent vraiment
connaître mon travail et la chaîne et
doit vraiment discuter avec moi puisque
j'ai beaucoup de demandes pour qu'on
fasse un vrai projet de vidéo et non pas
un placement produit pluri dior qui me
permettent de vous faire découvrir
quelque chose quelque chose
d'intéressant quelque chose de
concernant et que moi aussi je prenne du
plaisir de temps donc ça fait beaucoup
de choses puisque leur priorité c'est de
respecter le produit qui veulent placer
mais sur youtube vous vous demandez
souvent si les gens font un placement de
produit déguisée alors on va mettre les
choses au clair dès aujourd'hui quand je
ferai un placement de produit si un jour
j'en fais je vous le dirai tout
simplement jeu
non serait ce qui veut dire qu'à chaque
fois que j'ai parlé de sites internet de
livres de films de musique ou de quoi
que ce soit sur la chaîne j'étais pas
payés pour le faire et aujourd'hui je
vais vous parler de deux sites internet
qui sont mortelles et je ne suis pas
payé pour le faire je vais vous parler
rapidement du digit on c'est un truc que
je soutiens mort c'est une association
qui a lancé un site qui s'appelle le
digi ton point fr il est porté par les
deux sites internet les plus cool en ce
moment qui sont lilo et good dite vidéo
c'est un moteur de recherche vous mets
le lien dans le descriptif qui s'appelle
lille au point org
c'est un moteur de recherche vertueux
c'est à dire qu'à chaque fois que vous
faites des recherches vous avez de la
publicité ou générer des revenus
toujours est bien là la majorité des
bénéfices que ça dégage par pour des
projets sociaux à des projets
environnementaux est dans le même état
d'esprit même encore plus direct l'iag
août dit qu'un excellent excellent
excellent site ça vous permet de faire
des dons à des oeuvres que vous
choisissez non pas en faisant un
virement bancaire si vous n'avez pas les
moyens de le faire mais en regardant
quelques vidéos c'est comme si on vous
rémunérer pour regarder les vidéos vous
savez le modèle économique sur youtube
vous regardez des vidéos ça nous fait un
petit peu de revenus quand je dis un
petit peu je suis très au dessus de la
vérité j'en ai conscience
eh bien là c'est à peu près la même
forme sauf que votre argent vous savez
où il va c'est directement en dons à des
associations que vous sélectionnez c'est
pareil je vous mets le lien dans le
descriptif alors ces deux sites se sont
joints pour ouvrir une association
ensemble ils ont organisé donc le digi
ton la différence avec le téléthon c'est
qu'ici c'est que sur internet etc c'est
entièrement gratuit à aucun moment vous
allez sortir le moindre cents
pour cette première édition le but du dj
ton point fr et de réaliser leurs rêves
des enfants malades
nous allons faire alors nous les youtube
heures j'ai pas être le seul à en parler
mais vous aussi vous pouvez participer
en faisant vos recherches sur l'îlot ou
en visionnant les vidéos sur boutique
pendant toute la durée du 18 ans qui est
de quinze jours tous les revenus qui
vont être généré vont être donnés à
l'association petits princes qui depuis
1987 réalise les rêves des enfants et
des adolescents qui sont malades voilà
assez innovant c'est gratuit il n'y a
pas besoin de donner d'argent parce
qu'on peut pas forcément tous donné de
l'argent pour des dons officiellement ça
commence aujourd'hui ce 4 juillet à 17
heures si vous comptez participer en
allant sur l'un des deux sites ne serait
ce que quelques minutes faites le moi
savoir en mettant un pouce en l'air ça
nous permettra d'avoir une prévision du
nombre de personnes du groupe team
menthe à l'eau qui va participer au
digitaux merci beaucoup d'avoir regardé
cette vidéo jusqu'au bout pour vous
récompenser vous donne quelques espèces
sur cette semaine demain je vais
mentaliser yacine belhousse mercredi je
vous parle du mensonge des personnes qui
vous mentent ce sera la deuxième vidéo
que je sois là dessus j'en avais déjà eu
une c'était la 90 passé une excellente
journée
abonnez-vous avant de partir un rendez
vous demain à 17h ciao